which for those of you who know this
stuff you know that the fact that the
existing adiabatic operation algorithms
are based on stochastic hamiltonians is
probably not the reason that we've found
a lack of speed up and I'll try to
formalize some reasons for that in in
terminology that's maybe more familiar
to computer science but first I want to
cover some of the history of this
algorithm so we can understand the past
present and future so it starts with
transverse field adiabatic operation so
you want to do you want to minimize some
cost function over the space of n bit
strings by preparing the ground state of
some n cubed Hamiltonian that's diagonal
in the computational basis and your
scheme for doing this is to initialize
the qubits in the ground state of a
uniform transverse field and interpolate
from this beginning hamiltonian to the
problem a Hamiltonian and the adiabatic
theorem guarantees that if you do this
running for some total time that scales
polynomial polynomial e in the number of
qubits and the inverse minimum spectral
gap along the adiabatic path then the
suffice is to prepare the ground state
of the problem Hamiltonian ok so I call
this transverse field adiabatic
operation because it's not the most
general form of adiabatic operation you
could consider for example you could
also insert an additional extra
Hamiltonian in the middle of the
adiabatic path so maybe you have the
same beginning and final Hamiltonian but
in the middle you turn on something else
and it was noticed that in the early
days that for certain example cost
functions this non-trivial H extra can
improve the gap say from exponentially
small to to ordered one and then you
also have this more general concept of
adiabatic computation which is a
universal model so if you do ground
state eight about a kev Ellucian with a
local Hamiltonian and you also allow
yourself mythical measurement in
classical post-processing as we usually
do this is a universal model but it's
it's worth pointing out that in
universal adiabatic quantum computation
the final Hamiltonian is nothing like
this diagonal cost function but it's a
Fineman Kataya
circuit Hamiltonian so sometimes people
kind of blur the distinctions between
these three and that's why I'm setting
the terminology okay so what are some
historical heuristic reasons why
got so interested and excited about
adiabatic optimization so it's
implementable as an analogue algorithm
so there's there's hope that we could
build a device that does this long
before we could build a fault-tolerant
circuit model of quantum computer and
you know there's there's a nice history
where so opt is a ssin principles nature
likes to do things optimally or you know
physicists tend to think so and this is
inspired valuable classical opt is a
ssin algorithms in the past another
piece of intuition is that maybe quantum
tunneling could allow for faster
exploration of rugged energy landscapes
in the classical cost function and this
intuition can actually be leveraged to
obtain like to build toy problems that
exhibit this behavior where adiabatic
operation can be exponentially faster
than classical simulated annealing or
indeed any local search algorithm just
briefly to describe how those toy
problems work because I'll reference
them a few times later so so to get this
exponential speed-up you can use bits
metric cost function with a large energy
barrier that creates a local minimum and
so you can think that your initial
distribution it's completely polarized
so it's since your ground this and over
to having weight as you sort of turn
down the transverse field eventually you
find this local minimum and now if
you're doing something like classical
simulated annealing it's got very low
probability of ever stepping up onto
this barrier and because the barrier has
some polynomial scaling width and height
it's got very low probability of ever
stepping onto it and and then ever
crossing that plateau and so these
classical algorithms you know take to to
the height of the barrier time to solve
with local search but they but the
adiabatic algorithm attic opposition can
you know if the barrier is not too tall
or too wide then can solve it in linear
time what's the meaning of local search
algorithm here so so you do local search
on the space of bit strings so you're
only allowed to change a constant number
of bits in in each search
that's the phrasing that's used in bends
paper because like if we knew that this
was the landscape then
could make an algorithm that we just go
straight to zero you can you can spot it
by inspection is that what you mean so
so you could imagine for example
permuting the basis strings but keeping
the cost function the same right and
then you then you wouldn't know about
this structure anymore I would say so
this paper was in stock yeah okay but
the bad news is that we have no evidence
of a speed up using adiabatic operation
over the best-known classical
optimization algorithms certainly not
with local hamiltonians there are a few
results involving Oracle's so you can
obtain the grover speed-up using Oracle
hamiltonians that kind of resemble the
ones in adiabatic compensation you can
also obtain the Gloup Gloup tree
speed-up using a Hamiltonian Oracle that
is represents the adjacency matrix of
the Glu trees and and and this result
actually involves a nearly degenerate
Brown space so you have an exponentially
small gap to the first excited state and
you end up mixing in the ground state in
the first excited state but then you're
you have a polynomial separation to the
rest of the spectrum and you know then
you have sort of intellectual
descendants the QAM a superficially
resembles adiabatic operation and you
know briefly achieve the best
approximation ratio guarantee for that
problem and you know even even this year
it's you could see it as inspiring
various rigorous algorithm so the Google
group has a paper about something that
you could call reverse annealing so this
is you start in a classical basis state
you turn on the transverse field for a
short time and it lets you jump to
another low energy solution there's a
very detailed analysis in that paper and
then there's almost of the algorithm
we've just heard about which maybe kind
of overlaps or take some inspiration
okay but why is there no speed-up why
haven't we seen a speed-up is it because
the Hamiltonian is stochastic well so
even the empirical benchmarks just to be
clear it's not just that we we can't
prove there's a speed-up because even
the empirical benchmarks of using this
algorithm as a history
indicate any evidence of a speed-up over
the best classical algorithms okay and
the most well you know that's the Oracle
problem but I mean that's proven and the
most commonly cited reason for this lack
of speed up is that transverse field
adiabatic optimization is stochastic in
the computational basis so what does
that mean a Hamiltonian is called
sequest ik if in some choice of local
basis all of the local terms have matrix
entries that are zero or negative okay
and this word it's not just my
enunciation it's a combination of
quantum and stochastic so and physicists
have known about these these
Hamiltonians or recognize them for forty
years or more and they say they don't
have a sign problem this implies that
the equilibrium states are on the border
of quantum and classical physics so an
example of the stochastic Hamiltonian is
really the example so these transverse
Ising models so they're stochastic now
in the Z basis right here the matrix
matrix form of these poly operators so
you can see that all the off diagonal
elements are explicitly 0 or negative
and in fact it doesn't matter what's
along the diagonal of this Hamiltonian
so we can also consider generalized
transverse Ising models with disordered
interactions and in fact these
generalized transverse Ising models are
universal for stimulating stochastic
hamiltonians
and for stochastic adiabatic computation
this is one of these proofs that uses
perturbative gadgets so you pay a pretty
expensive polynomial overhead but as far
as you know maybe I'm serious we can we
can just focus on this class of
generalized transverse Ising models as
capturing the entire class of stochastic
Hamiltonians ok so what about these this
property about the the amplitudes in
equilibrium so so if the Hamiltonian has
real and non positive matrix entries
then you know minus beta H where beta is
some positive inverse temperature is a
non negative matrix non negative matrix
in trees so if you expand this guy
as a series right you're just adding up
every term in this series is a
non-negative matrix you are adding them
together therefore this e to the minus
beta H is a non-negative matrix and so
yeah yeah but sir yeah okay yeah so you
can always add an identity so so yeah
okay now as you take the limit to very
low temperature right the e to the minus
beta H well this is this written
unnormalized but it becomes the
projector on to the the say you have a
unique ground state it becomes the
projector therefore you can just see
from this simple calculation that
there's a choice of global faith's that
gives the ground state non-negative
amplitudes and in fact if the
Hamiltonian is an irreducible matrix in
the basis you're considering then all of
the ground state amplitudes are strictly
positive and so if you're transverse
fields are nonzero then you have an
irreducible matrix and so none of the
ground state amplitudes are 0 ok and so
further delving into the special
properties of these stochastic
hamiltonians
it really has to do with with their path
integrals don't mind the term Euclidean
it's for for physics reference so we can
expand the partition function as a path
integral right a sum over paths of some
product of amplitudes very similar to
the sum of our paths that we heard that
in Scott stop but in this case because
this e to the minus beta H over L L is
just some integer the length of your
path because that's a non-negative
matrix
so you can define a probability
distribution on the space of paths and
force for sufficiently large inverse
temperature this probability
distribution has the ground state
probability distribution as a marginal
on any sort of given time slice in the
path right so if you trace everything
out then you just get you get the either
the thermal probability distribution or
even the ground state probability
distribution ok so now having described
that I can tell you about the quantum
Monte Carlo algorithm and the idea is
just that you're gonna do Markov chain
Monte Carlo first a plastic path
integrals so because the ground state if
the Hamiltonian becomes a marginal of
against dish
tribution on a larger state space you
just rewrite all these path terms as as
some effective energy function then you
know really as long as you can as long
as you can efficiently sample from the
distribution then the path integral will
be a faithful approximation
you're not discarding entanglement or
anything like that okay so and this
quantum Monte Carlo works very well in
practice but the convergence of the
Markov chain is hard to theoretically
analyze and so we don't understand why
it works as well as it does okay now I
have to talk about d-wave the elephant
in the room so d-wave implements a noisy
version of transverse field adiabatic
optimization that they call quantum
annealing
you know the single coherent tines are
on the order single cubed coherence
times are on the order of nanoseconds
the annealing times are on the order of
microseconds yes
the limit we don't know the mixing time
of the Markov chain for this
distribution L so L you think of L is
polynomial I in
so so yeah you have these these facts
about the single cubed coherence times
being much less than the total annealing
times you can draw your own conclusions
there's also substantial open system
effects and calibration areas in the
device and yet it successfully solves
2,000 bit opposition instances so in my
opinion it works better than theory
might predict and maybe in some sense
convert confirms these ideas of inherent
robustus okay and so just to just to
tell you about the current status as I
know it so for instances to design to
give d-wave every advantage over its
classical competitors it it's able to
match the performance of the best
implementations of the best classical
algorithms on a modern single core CPU
so that's not something that is
completely easy to do and in fact the
classical simulations have improved by
orders of magnitude in just the last
five years in order to stay competitive
but that's how I would describe the
current status so so there specifically
for example designed to frustrate this
HFS algorithm the hands-free to selbee
algorithm that takes advantage of the
chimera structure of the d-wave graph so
they're pretty complicated they're
pretty contrived okay so they're 1,000
implemented switch were which were
actually designed
yeah but fresh-grated Loops is the is
the term used for them yeah okay okay
yeah they involved planting a solution
that's designed to foil some of the
stronger classical competitors 2d wave
yeah I mean the point is that they yeah
yeah I mean it has trouble they both
take a few seconds to find the answer
for 2,000 bits that's kind of the we
could at least do the 1,000 yes so
wasn't that actually the the 2013
quantum annealing without say she did
later yes so people still use spin
vector so now so now that algorithm with
with minor improvements is called spin
vector Monte Carlo and indeed people
still use it and if you just throw a
random instance right it's likely to be
easy and a lot of these methods
including the SVM C will beat D wave
yeah so it's only it's only when you
choose instances that really foil that
simulation and all the others at the
same time these particular instances
yeah
all these is nothing that's bent there
there's nothing it does better no no
that we could do it classically with
this very simple model and do it as well
as dances as women it doesn't see that
the way is no no bit bit bit but when
these are not the best our rhythms this
is just a very simple collab with ended
with a thousand you know just a thousand
so it's not really the best I reckon
it's something very very basic right so
that's the pose so so I'm trying to I'm
trying to give the best case scenario
but you're right that that many times
even this very simple algorithm yes so
this vastly superior to the d-wave
performance yeah okay I just want to
also share this slide about empirical
benchmarks that are actually based on
instances that are really built from
that spike problem I told you about
earlier so they're designed to foil
algorithms likes classical simulated
annealing and you know they the Google
group put out this paper in late 2015 so
you can observe a few things which you
know so so first of all this well the
first thing I notice is that the d-wave
scaling curve looks very similar to the
quantum Monte Carlo scaling curve but
they also pointed out that there's this
ten to the eighth factor pre factor of
speed-up you know so but also you're not
comparing against the best possible
classical algorithms for this particular
set of problems but what I actually just
mainly wanted to point out about this
slide is that even when they're saying
that d-wave is doing well and it's
beating classical algorithms that the
actual scaling curve seems very similar
to quantum Monte Carlo so I want to
reinforce this idea that you know we see
quantum Monte Carlo matching the
performance of the d-wave and that is
deserving of even further explanation we
don't again we don't understand the
mixing time of this this quantum Monte
Carlo Markov chain but for some reason
these scaling curves tend to match okay
so so we have the stochastic simulation
conjecture right this is this is one of
the old grand conjectures in in
hamiltonian complexity that stochastic
adiabatic computation can be classically
simulated into some time scaling
polynomial in the number of bits and the
inverse spectral gap in the sense set
in the sense of sampling the ground
state probability distribution in the
computational basis and okay so in order
to make this conjecture sensible it's
crucial that the gap refer to the
minimum gap because you know you could
for example take an np-hard instance or
you could take someone Samba love
np-hard problems with a unique ground
state and then when you perturb them by
a tiny transverse field you'll retain a
constant gap so it's it's crucial that
you don't refer to the instantaneous gap
of the Hamiltonian but the smallest gap
that occurs along the path in order to
get a sensible conjecture and this is
actually quite difficult because Markov
chains are designed to forget where they
came from and so making essential use of
the adiabatic path in your simulation
attempt is quite difficult and you know
there's kind of like a conventional
wisdom for people who have thought about
this problem that it's really about the
use of warm starts that is avoiding EE
exponentially small amplitudes in the
quantum ground state I can actually show
that this doesn't happen so so the
ground state amplitudes are never
smaller than this in the relevant
parameter regimes for these generalized
transfer sizing models and so you know
if you if you think of the the mixing
time of a Markov chain right it depends
logarithmic Leon the reciprocal of the
minimum probability of your stationary
distribution but because that's never EE
exponentially small these warm starts
are actually not the answer you need to
make even more essential use of the
adiabatic path okay so reviewing some
results on the stochastic simulation
conjectured yes yeah yeah how can you do
this
the graston has all states because I
mean isn't that yeah it is it is so so
the fear is that you have some states
some computational basis states with EE
exponentially small amplitude
all right so the most general sounding
result to date on the stochastic
simulation conjecture is the polynomial
time simulation of frustration-free
stochastic adiabatic operation and it's
a great result but I say it's general
sounding because because
frustration-free sounds like a very
general class but it doesn't include
this class of fresh created transverse
Ising model so it really it doesn't it
doesn't attack the stochastic adiabatic
operation in a sense and all the other
rigorous progress that we have are on
cases that we we know are easy for some
reason so for example ferromagnetic
models on any graph and essentially any
temperature and also the spike
Hamiltonians I told you about and 1d
models up to modest inverse temperatures
and actually even out of all of these
it's only the result about spike
hamiltonians that does use the adiabatic
path in a crucial way the others because
there's sort of no computational
complexity in the 1d models or in the
ferromagnetic models you can just kind
of jump to any setting of the parameters
and just run the quantum Monte Carlo at
that setting so and then finally all the
existing quantum so it's not just a
matter that we have a candidate
simulation algorithm and we don't know
how to prove it works because thanks to
math we know that all existing quantum
Monte Carlo algorithms are inadequate
for the most general form of the
conjecture because you always encounter
well you can there there are these two
types of obstructions and all the
variants of quantum Monte Carlo will
will will be foiled by either these
topological obstructions which have to
do with the winding of this this extra
path in the path integral or they have
to do with differences between the
amplitude and l2 the amplitude
distribution and probability
distribution okay so now I want to tell
you about something that is actually
quite simple but maybe surprises some
people so I'm gonna tell you about
quantum supremacy with stochastic ground
States
okay so stochastic adiabatic computation
can't be universal unless the pH
collapses because approximating
stochastic paths and girls is in post
PPP okay fine
but bravi and I'll define H to be
stochastic if there is any choice of
local basis in which the condition on
the matrix entries of H is satisfied
and so it's possible that you could have
a theoretical quantum Supremacy result
by sampling of stochastic Hamiltonian in
a rotated basis and in fact we all
thought about this just a few days ago
the output of an iqp circuit is the
ground state of a local Hamiltonian
where you've just applied local
rotations to a very simple yep
stochastic Hamiltonian ok so this how
this Hamiltonian uhu dagger is
stochastic but because it's the output
of a nike circuit sampling it gives you
theoretical quantum supremacy in fact
you can get even stronger results of
this nature one local rotation suffice
to make the 2d cluster state Hamiltonian
used in MBQ see explicitly stochastic
stochastic so this is a it's a bipartite
lattice you color the vertices red and
blue and you apply a Hadamard say to all
the red vertices and i decomposes here
stabilize our Hamiltonian into terms
that look like this there's actually a
minus sign in front of these and and
this actually has now recently appeared
in a paper by kissing key Fuji with the
with the title quantum speed-up in
stochastic adiabatic quantum computation
really it's it's he doesn't do the
cluster state he does the Union Jack
state and there's and there's more to it
but that's that's really what it is
you're not getting the speed up from the
adiabatic part of the computation
you're just you're preparing one of
these resource states and we know that
sampling those gives you quantum
supremacy so finally how can we evaluate
this non stochastic quantum adiabatic
compensation so I'm actually just going
to formalize the thing that Matt was
telling us about about localization I'm
gonna formalize that in terms of the
concept of conductance that we're
familiar with from Markov chains and it
also is something we could call an ISO
parametric inequality so we're gonna
relate the ground state geometry to the
spectral gap and basically it's about
generalizing a known result for Markov
chains in stochastic Hamiltonians to the
non stochastic case okay and if furthers
our understanding of the probability
distributions that can arise from the
escape node non stochastic ground States
that's the reference and so we're gonna
think of the labels of the basis as
vertices of a graph
and we'll think of the ground-state it's
a probability distribution on that graph
exactly like the picture of the
hypercube okay and then we're going to
connect two vertices to form this graph
by an unweighted edge if the
corresponding Hamiltonian matrix entry
is nonzero and then I wanted to find the
interior boundary of a set of these
vertices as those vertices inside the
set that are connected to something
outside of the set okay so now so here
just a bit more notation will make the
Hamiltonian positive semi-definite this
is this is the operator norm this is the
spectral gap it's just the bare spectral
gap above the ground state and so now if
you take any arbitrary choice of basis
and consider the ground state
probability distribution in that basis
and any subset with less than half the
total probability then you can
essentially use this to form a small
weight cut a variational state that
tells you that the spectral gap has to
be that small okay and the point of this
all right the power of this is in the
last two points here so it depends on
the range of the K local terms in the
Hamiltonian because those affects sort
of what we define to be the interior
boundary but not on the details of the
hamiltonian couplings not on whether
there's a sine problem or not and so for
a given probability distribution this
inequality constraints the spectral gap
of any local Hamiltonian having it as
its ground state in any choice of local
basis and so if you just take any
probability distribution that a Markov
chain will struggle on because it has a
set with small conductance then these
the you know having a non sequester
Hamiltonian is not going to help you to
satisfy to sample those types of
distributions using at least eighty of
added computation so kind of concluding
so simulated quantum annealing we
observe works really well for stochastic
adiabatic operation and so people say
that this non stochastic hamiltonians
are necessary for quantum speed-up well
necessary maybe but not sufficient but
so sampling a stochastic Hamiltonian and
a locally rotated basis can yield
theoretical and practical quantum
supremacy practical here meaning
quantum Monte Carlo gives you samples
from the ground state probability
distribution in the basis in which the
Hamiltonian is stochastic and you can
also use quantum Monte Carlo to compute
local observables in any basis but you
can't get samples from a rotated
distribution using that method yeah yeah
that was a couple fine thank you
there's a certain but if you take like
this sampling from that gives you a
certain power if you if you can sample
from a locally rotated or general
starquest exciting model is that the
same power is simply from that one or is
that a bigger power I think it depends
on how big of the local rotations you
use exactly right because you have to
decompose the K local interactions into
that transverse Ising form and would you
use these perturbative gadgets if you're
saying is it possible it gives you an
even greater power what can be greater
yeah simple instance of one of these
simultaneous would be one that's just
the transverse field or just a Z term so
if you work out more general Hamiltonian
that's both busy term and the transverse
field King or just a completely general
one yes it's full complexity classes
if you can sample that one rotated could
that be a bigger class or it's a little
hard to think about break because you
you you take this you take what you have
and you augment it with post-selection
and the point is that already after
rotating these one local guys and you
augment them with post-selection then
they become post vqp
right so so yeah you can't be much more
than that okay
so right so again one of the messages
here is that adiabatic computation with
non stochastic Hamiltonians is universal
but this doesn't mean that the non
stochastic hamiltonians will improve the
important performance of adiabatic
operation we just don't know and there's
some some reasons to see inevitable
limitations that is some explicit
probability distributions inevitably
take a long time to precisely sample
using purely adiabatic evolution and you
know part of part of the lesson here and
and you know Daniel made this point
earlier in the beginning of Matt's talk
is that maybe the spectral gap condition
is too pessimistic it's okay if you go
into the excited state if you just have
a few low lying solutions just more
generally you know it would be really
nice to have more general theoretical
conditions to capture the success of
these kind of algorithms that go beyond
the nests the sufficient condition of
having a large spectral gap because you
know it's so easy to show that those
spectral gaps become small these these
bare many-body spectral gaps so that you
know if we had a more robust condition
for why the algorithm works or not that
would be great and then also I think the
lesson from universal aid about a
computation is that measurements and n
sylla's are very powerful method Thanks
[Applause]
maybe join me so you know with the
stochastic condition so is there a way
that one can interpret Matthew Parker
saying whether you know it's the plastic
colonial but could you put one say just
instead of phase estimation lady but no
exact maybe it's more power via non
stochastic why I think I think one
answer I would say is like is that each
other's it actually could be good it'll
be spared to be some kind of you know
for the kind of speed up I was talking
about you wouldn't want to actually run
the idiomatic by a slow changing because
you need because you're talking about a
small overlap with the states
yeah so what I guess the question was
well in India that we do with you you
know with the conjecture would you still
believe this so so we expect at least a
quadratic slowdown in the spectral gap
because this like this this Grover
problem right these these Oracle
Hamiltonians can also be translated into
the quantum Monte Carlo context and
actually even a stronger observation is
this glue trees problem which is that so
even though you leave the ground state
and it's commonly said to be non
stochastic because you leave the ground
state right but we also said the thermal
density matrix has this special
non-negative matrix entry property so if
you're at sufficiently low temperature
you have just overlapped with the ground
state and the first excited state so it
does appear that at nonzero temperatures
right you can do something with
stochastic quantum annealing let's say
that you couldn't stimulate with quantum
Monte Carlo at least in an Oracle model
so you know there is some some sense in
which we might want to scale back the
stochastic simulation conjecture a
little bit like these obstruction
examples make essential use in my
opinion of non constant degree gadgets
to translate them into Ising models we
don't we don't have a but we don't know
that there are counter examples to the
state's rapidly mixing paths agirl Monte
Carlo in the case where you have bounded
degree interactions for example so maybe
maybe the conjecture should be made a
little weaker non stochastic you know
you
so you should just look at the
interaction graph which is correct but
then it is could you see the complexity
really goes into the fact that with one
surprise tickets
it's an irreversible walking so there
you know or you you or it's reversible
but in some way and so now now the
stationary distributions will be very
different and you can get to well in
that was kind of the point of the
conductance argument is that you you
can't avoid you know that that bound was
for the fully non stochastic case so
that so so okay but maybe one thing I
could say no no it's just vertex
expansion that was that was the point
yeah yeah it doesn't depend on the
details of the Hamiltonian couplings
it's just the probability on the
boundary over the probability in the
interior distribution yes yes it is
weighted by positive weights though yes
yes that can be true so actually I
didn't go into it but if you wrote out
the the full conductance form where you
count across the edges you see that the
the edges with the wrong sign actually
make the upper bound smaller so so but
but I will I will grant your point and I
agree that if anything the power of non
stochastic adiabatic computation has to
be not in how it arrives at the
distribution because it's foiled by the
same kind of distributions as Markov
chains are but just in in the fact that
we can't classically understand or
classically access that distribution so
the power would have to be in the
distribution rather than the dynamics
today's question get about that that we
think they're just just about work so
yeah you said they'd a bit so it seems
like there's maybe there's two weights
one weight is that there's the weight of
the wavefunction to this and we function
has very small probability somewhere at
this price watch but also where you say
one good thing about having all terms of
that will tell you with the same
scientists you don't get counseling at
this so absolutely absolutely yeah yeah
they could ask what were question yeah
so back to this simply gonna rotate a
basis yeah it seems like many states
that are got some any Hamiltonians we
think the ground state can be
approximated by something that's a local
quantum circuit applied to just the
products things
so do you think there could be some
extra power you know you can with these
simple things you can build some
topologically order states which can't
that's a state where you know if the
state is not ok that's interesting so in
those topological cases if you have a
degenerate ground state as well already
in the stochastic case right your your
your additional ground states will have
some negative phases as well so so yeah
could that give you some additional
power I'm kind of back to the the post
bqp thing when you augment it with
post-election but maybe I just didn't
understand
[Applause]